hey youtubers is charlie and the first
promo for a legend of korra book 3 just
aired in the netherlands on nickelodeon
it was mixed with footage from books 1
and 2 but i wanted to do a breakdown of
all the new things we saw and kind of
explain what it means about the premiere
for book 3 in the United States once
Nickelodeon officially announces
whenever it's going to premiere in the
United States and North America which is
probably enemy in June I'll start doing
more regular core videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a lot of fun I think it's going to be
a summer show this year so let's answer
some of the big questions first number
one why did this air in the Netherlands
and why are we just seeing it now and
why are the creators not saying anything
about it mostly because this footage was
a promo for the book to premiere in the
Netherlands that's right there just now
getting booked two spirits in the
Netherlands the reason why no one is
officially talking about it is because
the Nickelodeon office in the
Netherlands is responsible for making
these promos so Bryan and Michael you
know the creators have nothing to do
with this kind of stuff so that's why
they're not talking about it they'll be
a lot more publicly vocal as well as the
actors like Janet Varney whenever an
official US version of the trailer drops
which is going to be soon now to the
really important stuff what was that new
footage here is the breakdown first flow
décor in the Avatar state tu Corazon
Republic City using her waterbending to
pacify spirits see those spirit finds
that the dark avatar grew in the finale
yep they're sticking around those are
going to be the homes for the spirits 3
we see Korra fighting the White Lotus
for chorus fighting regular earth
Kingdom soldiers 5 shirtless Tenzin
airbending say what you will I'm sure JK
Simmons was smiling whenever he saw this
6 there's a shot of Korra boo me Tenzin
Jinora Bolin and Asami exiting one of
her airships they're going to use those
to travel around this season a lot of
you actually asked about eggs children
still being a part of book 3 here's your
answer the trio will still be together
even tho kya is not in this shot 7 a
white lotus member talking to a dragon
this means dragons are back just like
the sky bison in book two will have to
wait for an explanation as to how they
survived eight core of firebending
against another white lotus member this
could actually be one of the main
villains from book 3 or it could just be
a sparring partner and nine the final
shot is a dragon flying past a mountain
fortress in what looks like the Fire
Nation dragons are native to that
so it looks like we're going to get some
fire nation time in addition to earth
Kingdom stories so what does all this
footage say well the White Lotus is
heavily involved in the plot of book 3
they could be the villains or they could
be working with Korra it's hard to tell
based on these few clips the other big
takeaways are that the Fire Nation and
the earth Kingdom are huge destinations
for the story as well as dragons being
an integral part the biggest questions i
have now though r1r the White Lotus the
new villains or if they're not how are
they involved with corn the story and to
how are the Dragons involved with them
it looks like they're working with the
White Lotus now it's your turn let me
know what are your biggest questions
based on this new information i'll be
doing a legend of korra Q&A next week so
just leave all your questions in the
comments below like i said once they
announce an official premiere date for
korra book 3 i'll start doing more
regular videos which i'm expecting to be
either the end of May or early June
there are a couple big things that I'm
really looking forward to seeing in that
official trailer though you know namely
opal the earth Queen while we're waiting
for that everyone makes sure to go back
and watch last airbender book 3 that's a
big white lotus storyline in that book
right now click here for all of my book
3 videos I've done several so far and
click here to learn about my top 5 anime
villas thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives